welcome to the show everybody thanks for
being here thanks for listening I am in
Chicago right now because I was at
Northwestern University last night for a
for an event they're speaking to the
students and it was a great event it was
it was it was a lot of fun and you know
I thought it was a good turnout even
though there was some I'm sure totally
coincidental issues with the university
approving the event I mean they've been
trying to get approval yeah had been
trying to get approval for four weeks
and the university coin said dentally
didn't approve the event until like
three days before it which meant again
totally coincidentally that they weren't
allowed to advertise it until right
before the actual event but we still
filled the room and it was a it was a
good time what I want to talk about is
speaking of good times the the tide is
turning I think in America now I you
know I don't wanna be I don't wanna jump
the gun here I don't want to be overly
optimistic I'm not someone who's known
for being overly optimistic but I think
that maybe the tide is turning and
people are waking up and we're gonna
talk about that in light of this new law
that was just passed through this the
state Senate in Alabama so we're gonna
get into that but first I got to tell
you about Boland branch you know where
we're never going to agree on everything
as a country as a society but the one
thing that we all have in common is that
we like to sleep and we unless you're my
kids my kids hate sleeping but everyone
else and what all other humans love to
sleep except for my kids everyone else
loves to sleep and we could all use more
of it and getting a great night's sleep
is is easier than ever thanks to the
world's softest sheets brought to you by
bowline branch everything bowline branch
makes from bedding to blankets is made
from pure 100% organic cotton it's the
best material you could find for for for
bedding and blankets which means they
start out super soft and they get softer
with time everyone who tries Boleyn
branch sheets loves them that's why they
have thousands of five-star reviews just
listen to the what the customers have to
say and you can look at Forbes The Wall
Street Journal Fast Company all of them
are talking about Boleyn branch they
want you to love your purchase too so
they offer a no risk 30-day trial free
shipping so you've really got nothing to
lose
and you're not gonna want it you could
send them back but you're not gonna want
to send them back once you sleep on
these sheets you're not gonna want to
sleep on anything else so to get you
started right now my listeners get $50
off your first set of sheets at Bowler
branch comm promo code met go to Boleyn
branch comm today for $50 off your first
set of sheets that's B Oh L L and branch
comm promo code mat you know how to
spell that ma TT Boulud branch comm
promo code man all right now from life
news.com and Alabama bill that would
make aborting unborn babies a felony
passed in the State House on Tuesday
State House bill 314 sponsored by
representative Terry Collins would make
an abortion and attempted abortion of
felony exceptions would be allowed if
the mother's life is at risk
mothers would not be punished for having
an abortion under the legislation which
would make killing a baby in an abortion
a class 8-hour class a I should say
felony punishable by life or 10 to 99
years in prison for abortionist who kill
them lawmakers approved the ban on a
twenty five to six vote and it now heads
to pro-life governor K IV whose
Republican the legislation will take
effect
six months after it gets signed so this
is just on the heels of the law in
Arkansas so we've got two major pro-life
legislative wins in the span of a week
which means among other things that
probably roe v wade is going back to the
Supreme Court I think that's where this
is headed
and pro-abortion people are terrified of
that that's the last thing they want
because they know that the roe v wade
decision was they know if they if they
have any knowledge of all at all about
about that decision and they understand
how the Constitution works they know
that the roe v wade decision is a total
travesty and a in a joke a really bad
joke but no matter how you feel about
abortion the idea that they were able to
find a right to abortion in the
Constitution is obviously absurd that's
where it's going no I don't I talk about
being optimistic about the tide turning
and I am am i optimistic that the
Supreme Court with its current makeup
would actually vote to overturn Roe no
I'm
but there's a chance anyway there's more
of it there's at least a chance if it
makes it there but as I said the
pro-death crowd is growing very affair
afraid Cosmo had a headline yesterday
their headline was they put it very
simply it was it's time to freak the eff
out about abortion and nails a abortion
extremist group put out a tweet said
this is not a drill the goal is not just
to outlaw abortion in certain states
it's to outlaw it everywhere all caps
yes you're damn right you are damn right
we are gonna outlaw it everywhere that's
the goal and you should freak out if you
are Pro death you should definitely be
freaking out because the tide is turning
I'll tell you what what seems to be
happening here from my perspective this
is just my sense of things all right
this is not this is not based on any
survey data or poll data just my own
observations do with them at what you
will it seems to me that there has never
really been a point when a majority of
the country was avidly pro-abortion I
don't think that's ever existed I don't
think there's ever been a majority
pro-abortion you know country the avidly
pro-abortion crowd has always been small
they've been small but powerful powerful
because they're in positions of power
and because they have the indifference
of the American public on their side so
no matter what people say when they're
surveyed by by pollsters the fact is
that most of the country is has been
still as indifferent most people just
don't care that much so when the
pro-abortion people shriek and demand
their right to kill babies everyone in
the milk middle just goes as sure yeah
whatever and that's the dynamic that is
allowed abortion to continue in this
country that's what has protected the
so-called right to abortion the problem
pro-lifers have faced is that they have
this indifferent mass to deal with and
then even even the ostensibly pro-life
people on their own side relatively
active and aware and involved
conservatives people who are pro-life
but even a lot of those people haven't
really
considered abortion to be an important
topic now they agree with the pro-life
cause but they just don't feel like
fighting for it and that's what pro
lifers have been contending with here's
what seems to be changing the rapidly
pro-abortion people are still rapidly
pro-abortion that that hasn't changed
that's not going to change but what I
sense is that people in the middle and
then the disinterested conservatives I
think some of them are starting to wake
up that's what I see happening that
finally some of those other people who
have always been up for grabs by Pro
lifers finally they're starting to come
into the light I got a sense of that in
Philly at the rally even though you know
it's a thousand people compared to the
entire population of the country isn't
much but I really believe that what we
did in Philly we would not have been
able to do that five years ago or ten
years ago I think this is a reflection
of a change and much of it as I said ISM
is among conservatives conservatives you
know for decades because there has not
really been a wide conservative pro-life
coalition pro lifers have always been
sort of a subset of conservatism while
mainstream conservatism most
conservatives would look at the pro-life
cause and say you know yeah I agree with
you but I don't feel like arguing about
that I think that is really changing now
and conservatives are starting to see
they're starting to see two things
number one this really does matter
because life human life is at stake and
I think they've been helped to that
realization in seeing the increasing
radicalism of the pro-abortion side when
you've got these other laws in other
states where we go okay we could kill
babies through all stages of pregnancy
and you've got you've got Democrats
coming out and saying okay let's kill
babies after they're born or you know
we're gonna kill we're gonna kill the
kids either way members of that's what
what that one Democrat said it'd kill
him either way I put them in the
electric chair Kelvin abortion either
way the so that kind of stuff I think
has jolt
some conservatives out of their stupor
and they're saying wow I mean this is
really a these people really just want
to kill babies we can't allow this this
is this is horrible it when when the
pro-abortion case is stated honestly and
taken to its logical conclusion which is
what we've been seeing a little bit more
frequently recently it shocks the
conscience and so it's good that
pro-abortion but people have been doing
that because I think other I think
conservatives and some of the folks in
the middle have had their conscience is
shocked and that's what's happened so
that's part of it the other part of it
is that I think also conservatives are
starting to realize that this is a
winnable it's a very winnable issue
because our argument is so unassailable
is so self-evident is so just plain
right that we're standing up and saying
don't kill innocent human beings that's
our point it's it's the most simple and
unbeatable argument you can possibly
make and that that I think is how things
are changing now a couple things about
this Alabama law first much is being
made of the fact that it was passed
through the state Senate by exclusively
white males which of course is
irrelevant you know I always wonder when
people say oh these pro-life laws are
passed by a bunch of men well what's
your point that are you saying that men
are the only ones with the moral
intelligence to see that killing babies
is wrong well here's the good news we're
not the only ones now if we were the
only ones that would not really be an
insult to us would it be an insult to
everybody else but we're not the only
ones millions upon millions of women are
pro-life and as I've pointed out many
times the pro-life movement is led by
women you know I've been in this
movement a long time I've been to
pro-life events in dozens of different
states I've done you know callous
rallies and fundraisers and everything
else I've met and talked to thousands of
pro lifers I can say from experience I
can tell you for sure that this is a
movement
led by women uh you know as a man in the
movement I take a backseat and I'm fine
with that this is a movement led by
women but at any rate that the gender of
the person making the argument is of
course irrelevant because those awful
sexist men are making the case that it's
wrong to kill innocent and defenseless
human life so you know once you get past
once you get done with your tantrum
about their gender maybe you could try
to engage with the argument yeah get out
well they're men they're men okay
whatever fine yeah they're men all right
look we've established that oh the bad
bad men tisk tisk you shouldn't be men
that's bad to be men okay fine I'll
agree with you there let's for a sake of
argument let's agree they're men they're
terrible they're sexist blah blah blah
fine good okay we've established that
now let's talk about what they're
actually saying though can we get clean
can we engage with that second the other
point being harped on is that this law
does not allow exceptions for rape and
so the pro-abortion side is making this
all about that there this is all they
want to talk about this oh the law
forces women to carry their rapists baby
now as if this law was specifically
designed with that in mind which of
course it wasn't but that's all they
want to do they want to talk about the
hard cases they don't want to talk about
the 98 or 99 percent of cases that have
nothing at all to do with rape and
that's what we should be talking about
mainly because that is mainly what this
law deals with and the vast majority of
cases are have have nothing to do with
rape now as for the cases of rape which
are rare and in a very small minority
but as for them there are two things to
keep in mind
number one abortion helps rapists cover
up their crimes abortion apis love
abortion rapists Planned Parenthood is
the is a rapist best friend because you
if it when a rapist rapes someone and
creates a baby most of the time they
didn't that's not what they had in mind
they weren't trying to create a baby and
if this is a you know
what here the the people that are coming
up with these you know hardcase
hypothetical say well what if a 13 year
old girl is right now she's forced to
carry her baby well if a 13 year old
girl is pregnant that's a very good
indication that probably a crime
occurred and once you have the baby you
know you can do a DNA test and find out
who the father is and if that father is
know is an adult then that person is
going to jail so now we can prove we can
prove that a rape occurred
that's why rapist would rather just send
the victim off to Planned Parenthood
have the pregnancy taken care of and the
evidence thrown into a medical waste
dumpster and Planned Parenthood by the
way is more than happy to help with this
they're more than happy to just take the
money from the rape victim throw out the
evidence not call the cops or more than
happy to do what they do it all the time
so that's the first thing the second
thing is it's a very simple concept here
I of course have nothing but compassion
for rape victims and I have nothing but
contempt for rapists and if you wanted
to talk about a law that in acts
abortion for rapists if we're talking
about executing rapists then I'm all
ears on that discussion we could talk
about that but it is immoral to punish
an innocent third party that child
didn't do anything the child's not
guilty so punish the rapist but to
punish the rapists child is completely
and totally immoral and wrong obviously
and it's not gonna help anything it's
it's not gonna help the woman heal it's
not going to undo what is done what was
done and it's not going to help bring
about justice it's going to make it
harder to achieve justice
all right so that's that's the law in
Alabama let's see here I wanted to share
this with you yesterday I wrote
something trying to explain the left's
gender theories and I tried to put
myself into the mindset of a leftist and
which is it's a it's a very weird place
to be but I wanted to kind of explain
gender 9it gender dynamics from their
perspective it's bewildering and it
makes your head hurt but if you didn't
see that piece let's try to go through
this okay let's let me see if I can do
this from their perspective because
there are a lot of seeming
contradictions and people are very
confused about you know what what is
what do you what exactly is the less
gender theory now it seems like they say
a lot of first they're saying one thing
then they're saying something else that
contradicts the thing they just said so
let's see if we can let's see if we can
go through all right again from from
their perspective just explaining it to
you right-wing bigots so the first thing
that we have to understand is that
gender is a social construct right woman
and man are concepts that are
arbitrarily invented by society they
have nothing to do with reality a child
is assigned one of these labels randomly
at Birth by primitive backwards thinking
doctors who for no good or objective
reason have decided that a human child
with a penis must be a boy and a human
child with a vagina must be a girl these
words are interchangeable the body parts
are interchangeable none of it means
anything but remember that the generic
people we meaninglessly call women are
beautiful and power powerful and their
arbitrary womanhood should be constantly
celebrated all the time women have to
band together and lift each other up
women must be represented equally in all
of our institutions women are truly
wonderful splendid special creatures but
remember there is nothing special about
women literally anyone can be a woman a
woman is not anything in particular
person with a penis can be a woman
person with a vagina could be a woman if
a bucket of sand came to life and wanted
to be a woman it could be a woman to
anyone could be a woman so there is no
aspect of womanhood that is engrained or
biological or inaccessible to males and
womanhood
certainly has nothing at all to do with
your body parts that's the most
important thing but if you don't have a
uterus then you shouldn't be giving your
opinion on abortion no uterus no opinion
that's the model right we're tired of
men making decisions about women's
bodies but there is no such thing as a
woman's body trans women are women
remember a trans woman is just as much a
woman as a as as any other woman there's
absolutely no difference between the two
and to suggest otherwise is the height
of bigotry okay but anti-abortion laws
are sexist because they specifically
target women who are the ones having the
babies if men could have babies abortion
would be completely legal everywhere
right but men can have babies and women
can be fathers and fathers can be
mothers and mothers can be men and a man
can be a woman and women can be men who
are mothers I mean what's so confusing
about this how many haven't talked to
say it's very simple
men and women are exactly the same in
every way and anyone who belongs to one
group can just as easily belong to the
other because there's absolutely nothing
at all that objectively distinguishes
these two categories and therefore you
cannot say something about the one
category that does not apply just as
much to the other but women are
especially oppressed in our society men
don't know what it's like for women in
this country men have privilege and
institutional power and they can't
possibly relate to the struggles of
women that's why it's so important to
make sure that women are given every
chance to succeed without being hampered
by the you know by the unfair advantages
that are given to men but males should
be allowed in female sports it is
unthinkable to oppress a biological male
by refusing him entry into female sports
if the other girls don't like it then
you know what they should check their
privilege and shut their bigoted mouths
but women must stand up and speak out
against unfairness they must be able to
claim their own spaces what belongs to
them must not be appropriated but drag
queens are gorgeous and amazing there
are few things more beautiful than the
sight of a man in women's clothing and
fake breasts dancing around on stage but
men are scum but men are women
but patriarchy but social construct but
girl power but I'm confused
it's all very confused it's all
incoherent do you know why because
coherence is for bigots okay that's what
this comes down to now do you understand
hopefully you do I'm glad that I could
clear that up for you all right um
before we get to emails I was planning
on talking about this story I had I had
set aside like 20 minutes for because
it's so great but I feel like the rug
has been pulled out from underneath me
there maybe you saw this online it was
kind of going viral over the last few
days there's a story out of South Africa
about a man who reportedly was had been
going to KFC I don't know if it was the
same same KFC or different KFC's but he
had been going to KFC for a year eating
for free claiming to be a food inspector
from the head office who was had been
sent there to to inspect the chicken and
taste it and that was the story anyway
and it is apparently the guy had been
arrested which is totally unjust but
then as I was just doing a little bit of
background research to talk about it I
saw that apparently this story has been
called into question
and now KFC has denied that such a thing
ever happened or that such a person
exists now I don't know if that's just
them covering their tracks because
they're so humiliated I don't know maybe
we'll never know but we can only just
hope that this man is out there
somewhere this mythical legend of a man
who who you know you could say all you
want that it's dishonest it's stealing
and yeah it's all those things but this
is a man who believed in something yes
this is a visionary this is someone who
had an idea and where other people would
say oh that's crazy you can't do that he
said I'm going to do it and he did
unless he doesn't exist but let's just
assume that he does wonderful and
inspiring story all right
let's get to some emails Matt well show
at gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Michael says hi Matt I'm 23
years old and have been a type 1
diabetic since I was 17 I work in an
office buying parts and find my job
absolutely miserable since I was little
I've dreamed of serving my community and
putting my body on the line in order to
protect my community in the country I
love
I spoke with three different military
recruiters during my time in college but
the conversation never lasted longer
than a few minutes once they found out
about my condition I plan on applying
for my local fire department in the fall
but I'm worried I'll have the same
result I know I will find value in
raising and practicing raising and
protecting a family someday but I don't
know how much longer I can work in an
office do you have any advice about
vocation or about finding meaning and
remedial jobs that don't seem to impact
the greater good I'm struggling to see
how I'm making a difference
you're incredible thanks for all you do
first of all I think your desire to have
a job where you're protecting your
community is very noble and so you
should be commended for that and you
know I don't know maybe that I'm not
sure what the rules are and fire
departments as opposed to the military
what they're you know what their
physical standards are or whatever but
it's quite possible that that could work
out but as for the job that you have now
I think that it is and I'm not just I'm
not just saying this I really do believe
that to go into an office and work what
you refer to as what a remedial job
which isn't the word I would use for it
but to work a job like that in an office
working a job you don't really like that
that also is a noble pursuit and that
takes that takes determination that
takes you know I would even say you know
it takes courage in a way to go doing a
job that you really don't like that you
hate doing but to go in every day and do
it anyway because you know it's your
responsibility and because you want to
have a family one day and then when you
have a family you continue doing it to
protect them and and to provide for them
because there are a lot of people NT of
people in our country today who will say
I and I don't want to do this job I
don't know what to do that once I'm not
gonna do any job I'll just live off the
government or I'll live off my parents
or whatever I don't want it because if I
don't want to want to spend my time
doing something I don't want to do so I
have a lot of respect for someone who
says ok I'm gonna go I don't like doing
it but I'm gonna go in and do it anyway
and so I think you can find I think you
can find some real nobility in that and
I think that you are impacting the
greater good in that sense that you're
fulfilling your obligations you know
you're doing your duty and that
certainly contributes to the to the
greater good and that also provides an
example to others around you so what I
would say is obviously keep doing that
job for now but how old do you say you
say you're 23 years old well look I mean
you're doing that job you have the sense
of duty so that's a great sign there's
no reason to assume though that you're
gonna be in this job for the next 40
years I mean these days nobody stays in
one job for 40 even if you like the job
and want to stay there you probably
won't so you got your whole life ahead
of you and I would say keep doing this
job and keep whatever your dream sort of
job is and whatever you really want to
do keep pursuing that in the meantime
don't give up on the job that you have
keep that but also pursue the sort of
job you want so don't give up on that
dream I think that you'll you'll find
early 23 I mean it's you you still got
quite a lot of time to find that job and
you know and and invest yourself in a
vocation that is really meaningful to
you and I have confidence that you will
you will find that this is from Gareth
says to the future unquestioned King
Emperor and grand master of this and all
other worlds recently I've been asking
questions about what will happen when
you take your power rather than add to
the growing list of your of those
incurring your wrath by questioning your
plans I'd like to offer my service as
your lieutenant and helping you to
subdue the masses and setting up your
theocratic dictatorship I vow to crush
your enemies to drive them before you
and fill your ears with the limitations
of their women thank you for reading
this this unworthy letter
okay may you live forever Gareth your
desire to serve beside me makes me
concerned that you are planning to
sabotage and overthrow my regime now of
course if you did not want to serve me
then I'd be concerned that you're
disloyal and rebellious so basically
either way you're off to the gulag
sorry about that fortunately in my
abounding mercy first-time offenders
will only have to serve 35 years of
forced labor
unless you've been accused of treason
which is what I'm accusing you of in
which case it's a hundred years so you
know but those are the rules
really I can't do anything well I could
do something about it but I don't want
to because of my cruelty cruelty and
mercy yes it's a it's an interesting
combination
let's see says dear Matt I would first
of all like to thank you for the work
you do and especially for the clear and
helpful arguments you make about why
abortion is evil as a new mother and
human being that issue was especially
close to my heart and it's been
sickening to watch the events in New
York and Virginia unfold so thanks for
fighting the good fight I'm from Hungary
and moved here last July to join my
husband who's an American I say all this
to give a little context I am a
Christian and a conservative and I
haven't really enjoyed listening to
podcasts about American politics and I
found my views line up with most of
those professed by the smart thoughtful
and well-read conservative thinkers I
look up to however the one area in which
I feel there's a lack of nuanced
solution finding is gun violence what I
see is what we call ostrich politics
because apparently ostriches when
sensing danger dig their heads into the
sand not realizing that just because
they can't see the danger anymore it
hasn't evaporated how they're still not
extinct is beyond me but I digress
that's kind of what you know
two-year-olds will do also when they're
playing hide-and-seek they'll cover
their eyes and they think that they they
have disappeared and you can't see them
anymore so it's similar sort of thing so
what I see is slightly disappointing to
me because every time the topic comes up
the right seems to restate their stands
and then use the affirmation tactic and
end the discussion I have no idea what
solution what a solution might be but
I'd like to at least hear conservatives
discuss the issue would it be our duty
to try to find ways to minimize the
chance that a horrific incident like a
school shooting might occur even if we
think perpetrators can turn their knob
turn to enter turn to knives or other
means
of inflicting harm the analogy that came
to mind for me is this you have
electrical outlets in a house and also a
child who routinely starts crawling
towards them and poking at them what do
you do you clearly can't remove the
outlets they're given they're here to
stay but do you say man if I stop the
kid from poking this one he'll still
find another one and even if I stopped
every attempt you can still fall down
the stairs and hurt himself that way or
get hit by a car whatever if it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen I would hope
not and if it's mental illness and not
the guns there's got to be something
that could be at least attempted to try
to address that by the way I cannot
believe that the reason there's
basically no gun violence in for example
Hungary is because there just aren't as
many mentally ill people the country has
been completely ravaged by the world
wars then Soviet rule it was just
emerging from communism when I was born
in Healthcare's a mess I have to think
guns have something to do with it but
let's say that that's even beside the
point because of the Second Amendment so
guns are here to stay ok is there really
nothing further to be said after that if
there is there nothing we can try to do
as a society even if it falls way short
of stopping every single shooting is it
really more guns I feel very uneasy
about that solution also just an added
question because I hear this a lot if
the government comes for you you have to
be able to protect yourself
students in Budapest led an uprising
against communist rule in 8 1956 and
they did quite well right up to the
point where the Russians sent in their
tanks if the government wants to get you
they will not be deterred by any arsenal
of guns you might have
however impressive or am I not seeing
something
I hope the letter isn't too long it gets
tossed in the spam right away no I have
I don't I don't I have no problem with
long letters so I don't mind reading
either way I very much appreciate your
integrity and spine something that's a
very rare trait these days best wishes
that I give out this person's name Lilla
from Lilla I think is how you pronounce
it all right Lilla hopefully I'm
crossing your name right
I appreciate that email and I think you
what you express is very coherent and
intelligent thoughtful and there's
nothing wrong with saggin I think that
there are some there are probably many
conservatives who are so dogmatic about
guns that even what you've just said
there they're just going to shut you
down
I'm not even how you're a heretic for
even saying that I don't take that
approach I believe in gun rights
I am a pretty hard line on that but I'm
not dogmatic in the sense that I we can
talk about it I mean I can understand
there are it's it's not like it's
unreasonable to make an argument and say
well maybe we should restrict that or
this or that gun I'm probably going to
disagree with the argument you make but
it's not an unreasonable argument and I
think this is one thing we have to just
I don't want to get sidetracked and not
address your question but you know we
one of the reasons why discussions our
discourse in this country is so fruit'
often so fruitless is that we treat
every opposing argument as totally
unreasonable and we don't realize that
it's possible to be to be reasonable and
wrong and if someone is reasonable and
wrong then we need to we should just
talk to them and have a human discussion
and we don't need to treat them like
they're like they're morons right so
that's the issue now there so there are
some arguments that really are
completely unreasonable like the
argument that a man can be a woman well
that's an unreasonable ridiculous
argument and so we can't treat it like
it is reason but we should engage with
it and try to explain why the person is
wrong but we cannot treat that argument
like it's intelligent or reasonable or
like we understand their point of view
because it's not intelligent we don't
understand it it's it's because it's not
understates it's it's not a coherent
rational argument there is nothing to
understand
so that's that's the the point there as
for the issue of guns here's here's
where I stand on this I agree with you
that we do need to do something focusing
in on the school shooting thing I do get
uncomfortable when you have
conservatives who will constantly point
out that oh you know actually there
aren't really there there hasn't been an
uptick in mass shootings that's just a
kind of a figment of our imagination
because of the way the media reports
this stuff and if you look at the
statistics it's not any more common now
than it is that it was back then and
kids aren't any aren't at any more risk
today for of a school shooting than they
were say 30 years ago I mean
statistically that might be true but
it's we're not imagining things
you do have these school shootings that
happen every single year now and I don't
think it's always been that way
I remember when when Columbine happened
and the reason why Columbine sticks out
to us why it was this this event this
kind of history changing event is
because no one had really seen anything
like that before
now it's it seems like every couple of
years there's a there's a shooting like
that and that's not normal and if it is
normal it shouldn't be so we do need to
accept that there's a very real problem
here we need to do something in my
opinion and you might not like this
answer based on what your on your email
there my opinion is the most direct way
to address that problem is to protect
our children in school because the fact
what you said there about what guns our
reality they're there anyway that really
is true now you do have the second
Amendment which is not a small thing it
is it's the it's the say comes right
after free speech obviously our founding
fathers found it to be very important
and you can't just toss it out the
window even if you could prove to me in
a crystal ball that well if we could
just give her to the Second Amendment
then it wouldn't cause mass shootings to
go down well still the amendment still
exists we still have that Liberty we
still have that freedom it's just like
if you could prove to me that well if we
get rid of a free speech it would it
would have this and that positive effect
yeah but we still have that freedom and
it's still there so we can't we can't
ignore it we just can't do that
it's law its Liberty we can't ignore it
but even aside from that the fact is
there are tens of millions of guns out
there and it is true that if somebody
gets it into their head that they want
to kill mass numbers of people they have
the desire to do that we talked about
this last week about desire and
opportunity the reason why most of us
are never going to do a school shooting
is because we have absolutely no desire
to do that and we never will
there are people whether through
spiritual evil or mental illness
whatever you want to say who find in
themselves that desire to kill mass
numbers of people and then once they
have that desire all they're looking for
is the opportunity and there simply is
no law that's going to deprive them of
that opportunity that's the fact which
it seems like you know so do we say oh
well they're gonna do it anyway there's
nothing we can do absolutely not
I think we need to be taking proactive
steps to defend and protect our children
in these schools we need to be doing
real things real active measures and one
of those things is to make sure that
every school in America has armed
security and I know we might like that
we might say wow we shouldn't have to
look we shouldn't live in a country
where you need armed security in a
school yeah we shouldn't but we do and
so we should have it there's armed
security and pretty much any other
government building you can think of
public schools are government buildings
and it pretty much any other government
building you could think of there's
armed security you go to the Social
Security office
I wonder worth you know when I got
married we went there for with my wife
and I went there and just a little small
office with a few people sitting there
in the waiting room and there's an armed
guard sitting there and to protect what
documents papers so if we've got armed
security to protect documents and papers
and armed security to protect
politicians in Washington then I think
we our children who are in government
buildings also deserve that same
protection so that's what I would do and
that's not that's not an ostrich in the
sand that is taking real active steps
because going back to opportunity now
there's nothing we could do about the
fact that people are going to develop
this desire that's going to happen we
can't stop that from happening as far as
depriving them of opportunities well a
law is not going to take the opportunity
because a law is just it's just a
concept right in terms of
from a preventative perspective like if
I want to kill someone you say well
there's a law against killing people
okay but it's not it's not gonna
physically stop me from doing it that
will allow you to punish me after the
fact which is good but it's not going to
physically stop me I think what we need
to do on top of having laws is we need
to have actual physical barriers that
may prevent may hinder my opportunity to
do the bad thing and that physical
barrier in this case would be armed
guards I think would be very difficult
to argue that you know a school shooting
where there's an armed guard is is
likely to be just as deadly as a school
shooting where there is no guard I think
about Sandy Hook I mean those kids those
poor kids were just sitting there in the
classroom
utterly defenseless until the police
arrived I think it's I think it's
immoral and wrong to leave our kids
defenseless like that and so that's what
I would that's how I would address it
and I think that I think that is a
proactive step that we could take thanks
for the email I guess we will leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show you know repealing
roe v wade would be a good thing because
it might be a step on the way to not
killing so many babies but it would also
be good for the left and I'll explain
why on the Andrew Clavin show we've also
got the mailbag I'm Andrew Clavin